welcome to the David Pacman show I am
not David Pacman and while you may think
that I am an out of work Jim Gaffigan
stunt double I am indeed Jesse dalamore
host of the dollar more daily on YouTube
this past Friday
a the the the the the brutal beating
tape of uh Tyree Nichols was released
the brutal beating that took place at
the hands of the Memphis Police
Department
an elite group of police officers the
most highly trained on their staff took
part in the beating that ultimately led
to his death I'm not going to play the
footage here it is out there it is
public you can find it on Twitter really
anywhere you just do a Google Search and
you'll find it
foreign but I want to talk a little bit
about what was released and the timing
of the release on a Friday night it
seemed
strange to me and then we're going to
talk about some ghoulish takes from the
right notably Fox News and Jesse Waters
first though if you haven't seen it it
is gruesome and and
the lack of humanity that was displayed
will rock you if you are not careful
about how much you consume of it
disgusting just a complete disregard for
the life and well-being of Tyree Nichols
it also goes because they were in
the Scorpion unit which has now
apparently been disbanded but they were
members of an elite police unit and it
was like the Keystone Cops
they were pepper spraying one another
they were injuring themselves while
trying to administer a brutal beating on
this civilian on the citizen on this
uncharged not convicted unarmed
individual
it was gross to say the least
and what you would expect from Fox News
uh didn't quite come to fruition I was
actually a little shocked at some of the
more reasonable takes than you would
expect
it didn't just devolve into just comply
and this won't happen
here's Jesse Waters while still sucking
up to police and showing deference for
police departments no matter what the
charges against them are
he still seems a little bothered by the
footage watch this
one mother lost four children four Sons
to homicide before the age of 30.
and so we just has to stop and these
officers uh black officers in a in a
black neighborhood they're working on a
crime task force and they had really
really made a lot of arrests from when
this task force was put up and running
in October and had really cleaned up the
streets but now to watch this
this is hard to see and I think we have
another tape again it's about two
minutes viewer warning another body cam
this is graphic watch he's almost there
he's almost there
they were working on a crime task force
and they had made a lot of arrests and
had to really they had really cleaned up
the streets but to watch this is It's
hard to see he says but he doesn't quite
get there he doesn't quite ask the right
questions of did they affect the arrests
they affected because of the fact that
used they used brutality and illegal
means to do so
are they not going to question that
these cops don't feel constrained by the
Constitution to which they sworn oath to
support and defend
Jesse Watters went on to have Heather
McDonald on who is uh protect the cops
at all costs
um
besmirch the the the prospect of
diversity training within police
departments of implicit bias training
and of course they go to her the expert
quote unquote and this is how that
devolved and then we're going to talk
about exactly how she's wrong with some
facts with some data with some research
let's bring in the author of War on Cops
we have Heather McDonald here Heather
take us out big picture statistically I
mean this is this is extremely rare
well absolutely and you know Jesse this
looks like absolutely terrible tactics
cops are desperate for more tactical
training and de-escalation and stress
control so they're not put in an in a
position that they feel they need to use
uh lethal force and instead they're
being given implicit bias training
diversity training complete waste of
money but the narrative that is being
put on what looks to be a very horrific
incident is inflammatory it's coming
from the president on down that we are
living through an epidemic of racially
biased police killings of black men that
is completely false President Biden just
said oh the the criminal justice system
denies equal treatment to blacks he
should know better study after study
coming out of Harvard out of Michigan
State University out of the left-wing
Center for policing Equity shows that
there is no bias in fatal police
shooting so Jesse Waters proclaims this
is extremely rare
I think we all know any of us who are
paying attention for for any amount of
time relative to the treatment of police
the civilians by police in the United
States especially related to the
treatment of unarmed black men is that
this isn't an exceedingly rare or
extremely rare as he categorized it it's
an all too common occurrence
and McDonald's saying that she blames
diversity training and implicit bias
training that we need more use of force
training that's what we need for police
and then she makes the Bold claim that
there was no racial bias there is no
racial bias in police in fatal police
shootings and this just flies in the
face
of what we know I'm going to read a
little bit from this Guardian article
just one paragraph here the guardian
article entitled if you want to read the
entire thing
it never stops killings by U.S police
reach record high in 2022 law
enforcement killed at least 1
176 people or about a hundred people a
month last year making it the deadliest
for police violence
and this is the paragraph
black people were 24 of those killed
last year while making up over only 13
percent of the population from 2013 to
2022 black residents were three times
more likely to be killed by U.S police
than white people the inequality is
particularly severe in some cities
including Minneapolis where where police
killed black residents at a rate 28
times higher than white residents and
Chicago where the rate was 25 times
higher
and that comes from mapping police
violence those statistics that I just
read you
so this this claim this bold Fox News
talking point is nothing but nonsense
and lies and and subterfuge
it is plain cute with actual crime
statistics and statistics related to
police brutality
mapping police violence also has this
chart
there's a racial disparity even in who
the police killed while they're running
away not the police
the the suspect
one in every three people killed by
police was running away driving away or
otherwise trying to flee black and brown
people were more likely to be killed
while fleeing
so
the nonsense that Fox News will try to
to perpetrate upon the American people
even in the wake of a brutal
gang style slain of a citizen is
remarkable Republicans are raw raw raw
on waiving their constitutions
they're rah-rah-rah about
anti-establishment
and the Deep State and being scared of
the government but when it comes to
Armed agents of the state
who brutally use the power they've been
granted their arrest power the power to
take the lives of citizens it's crickets
from the peanut gallery of conservative
the the hierarchy of conservative media
they protect the cops Law and Order they
say while calling in to question the
Integrity of government everywhere else
it doesn't make
any sense